نجم جديد في نادي النصر السعودي ليس اين
اسم بل هو النجم يبدا كريستيانو رونالدو
فصلا جديدا في مسيرته التاريخيه في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض امام الالاف في
ملعب مرسول بارك تم تقديمه اللاعب الحاصل
على خمس كرات ذهبيه كافضل لاعب في العالم
وصاحب الارقام القياسيه التي لا تحصى يقول
رونالدو انه جاء ليجعل جماهير النصر سعداء
ويقولوا ايضا انه يريد ان يشارك في
المباريات في اقرب فرصه ممكنه في ما يؤكد
رئيس النصر ان صفقه رونالدو تؤكد ان
الدوريه السعوديه قادر على استقطاب
الاسماء الكبيره
[موسيقى]
معنا من الرياض الان مراسل العربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي يرصد لنا المزيد من
التفاعلات والاصداء وردود الافعال بعد
تقديم نادي النصر لكريستيانو رونالدو على
اثر وصوله الى الرياض امس اذا اليك عبد
المحسن الكلمه لك وايضا لضيوفك من معجبي
ومحبين هذه النصر
بالفعل طاهر كانت ليله غير عاديه لعشاق
النصر وكذلك عشاق كريستيانو رونالدو الذين
توافدوا الى الملعب مبكرا لرؤيه رونالدو
في ظهور الاول على ملعب مرسول دارك
ومرتديا قميص نادي النصر تضمن الحفل
العديد من الفقرات حيث منذ وصول كريستيانو
رونالدو بدات فقرات الحفل قبلها كان هنالك
مؤتمر صحفي لكريستيانو رونالدو برفقته
رئيس نادي النصر ومدرب نادي النصر تحدث
كريستيانو عن امور كثيره في من خلال هذا
المؤتمر تحدث عن انه تلقى العديد من
العروض الاوروبيه ولكنه اختار نادي النصر
وقال باني همم جئتم هنا للفوز وتحقيق
البطولات وايضا تحدث عن امر اخر مهم وهو
مشاركته في الرؤيا التطويليه لكره القدم
في السعوديه وهذا ما تحدث به رئيس نادي
النصر بان هذه الصفقه ليست رياضيه فحاسب
بل تت ذلك الى امور اخرى في الحقيقه ردود
الافعال كبيره طاهر لدى مشجعين نادي النصر
بعد هذا همم هذا التقديم التاريخي
لكريستيانو رونالدو ربما ناخذ بعض
اللقاءات لنرصد ردود الافعال اليوم كيف
شفت تقديم كرستيانو رونالدو وكريستيانو
رونالدو كنت تشاهد على الشاشه طوال
السنوات الماضيه اليوم شاهدته مرتدي قميص
ناديك المفضل كيف شفت هذا الموضوع همم
تشوف اللاعب اللي تشوفه دائما في شاشات
ويكون يعني هو قدوتك في كره القدم قدامك
همم كان الجمهور حماسي همم كلهم
كانوا معه همم تدريب كان جميل جدا صراحه
استمتعنا كلنا يعني كيف شايف كرستيانو
مسيره تبع نادي النصر همم
اضافه ممتاز النادي النصر الدوري السعودي
راح تساهم ارتفاع ركن الدوري
السعودي يرتفع بالترتيب العالمي همم ااا
وتصير انديه الدوري السعودي افضل على شكل
عام
بيل طاهر كما تحدث احد مشجعين الان بان
كانت الهتافات عاليه لدرجه ان مذيعي الحفل
كانوا همم يهدئون الجمهور قليلا نظرا
للحماس الشديد والهتافات لكريستيانو ايضا
تقليد حركه الحركه الشهيره لكريستيانو لدى
المشجعين ايضا همم ناخذ بعض اللقاءات همم
كيف كيف شفت اليوم كيف شفت كرستيانو اليوم
شعور جميل
مول المفرح اننا نراه في الدوري السعودي
وفي الفريق معروف عالميا النصر وان شاء
الله الجايات اكثر ونشوف الدوري السعودي
اكثر من افضل الدوريات اللي في اوروبا
شكرا شكرا طيب هنا ايضا كيف شايف مسيره
كريستيانو الان في الدوري هل سيحقق وسيجلب
كريستيانو البطولات للنصر فريقك والله
اولا نبارك للجماهير العالميه هذه الصفقه
الرائعه
النصر جميعهم اليوم محتفلين وان شاء الله
البطولات قائده وتحقيق ان شاء الله الاعظم
والافضل مع الاعظم والعالمي مع العالم ان
شاء الله تحياتي اذا طاهر هذه هي الاجواء
خارج الملعب بعد انتهاء كافه فقرات الحفله
التي انتهت في همم تقديم لاعبين النصر
وكذلك الفريق الفني همم حصه تدريبيه همم
للمره الاولى همم امام الجماهير التي
حضرها الكثير من مشجعين
ما انا مستعد هذه الصوره
عد اليك وهذه صور مباشره تصلنا بينما
نتابع في الحديث معك عن هذا الموضوع ولو
نتابع صوت طبيعي
[تصفيق]
وكريستيانو رونالدو يشارك اذا في تدريبات
نادي النصر للمره الاولى بعد اتمام هذه
الصفقه ووصوله وتقديمه من قبل ناديها
الجديد وعبد المحسن الحربي اللي عم يغطي
الموضوع ما بتقدر اكيد تكون نموذج متجرد
من مشاعرك وعواطفك 100% انك نصراوي كما
عرفت انك حاولت كثيرا ان تاتي بطاقه ولكن
لم تستطع هل هذا ما حصل فعلا
بالفعل طاهر كان في المؤتمر الصحفي
كرستيانو رونالدو اا كانت ايضا كثير من
المشاعر بصفتي صحفي غير رياضي همم حاولت
انا اتجرد كثيرا من هذا المشاعر ولكن
الحدث تاريخي وعظيم طاهر اكبر من تكون
متجرد الى درجه كبيره ولكن هذا هذا القدوم
لكل فرح به ليس اا مشجعين نادي النصر فقط
بل كل مشجعين الانديه الاخرى الذين ايضا
حضروا وتوافدوا الى ملعب المباراه شهد
الكثير من مشجعين همم الهلال الاهلي
الاتحاد همم رؤيه نجمهم الاول لكرستيانو
رونالدو الذين كانوا يتابعونه عبر الشاشات
طوال اكثر من 15 سنه ولكنه الان يتواجد في
دوري روشن السعودي
همم مباشره امامهم ف- هذه لحظه تاريخيه
طاهر بالفعل بكل تاكيد الجميع
محاوله التجرد ولكن الذي يستطيع وهذه
الصور التي نشاهدها ايضا تاريخيه لتدريبات
النصر همم نتفهم ذلك بطبيعه الحال همم
ولكن على الاقل تخرج لنا بالقميص الاصفر
المره القادمه شكرا جزيلا لك عبد المحسن
الحربي مراسل العربيه من الرياض تحياتي
اليك